I'm not an atheist anymore because I
don't look at the world that way anymore
I'm not a materialist anymore I don't
think the world's made out of matter I
think it's made out of what matters it's
made out of meaning look at it from a
from the perspective of modern brain
science what we orient towards
unconsciously which means what captures
our attention is meaning and it captures
our attention before we know what it is
the brain acts as if the world's made
out of information or made out of
meaning Heidegger for example German
philosopher was convinced that the world
was made out of meaning essentially and
that people's primary interaction with
being was interaction with meaning and
that isn't what modern people think
because they're deeply materialistic to
go back 400 years or 500 years and you
look at what people meant when they said
matter which is what things are made out
of what they thought matter was isn't
like what we think it is it wasn't like
this material stuff sort of like dirt
that everything was made out of it was
it was much more complicated than that
problem with the standard view of matter
is that it doesn't really deal with the
fact that matter comes in arrays and in
patterns and the patterns and the arrays
which is sort of lost when you think
about atoms that's where all the action
is that's where the reality is God
creates Adam and Eve explicitly in his
own image there's a variety of
interpretations about the first being
that God created so there's a tradition
in medieval Christianity and Judaism as
well that the first man was
hermaphroditic and male and female
together and then separated into two
separate entities which then were
forever looking to be rejoined and
there's a very profound psychological
idea there which is that the union of
masculine and feminine produces a kind
of perfect wholeness and you can think
about that as being expressed
biologically given that males need
females and masculine needs feminine but
you can also think about it as
different aspects of the psyche or
between people or different aspects of
the psyche within people
so whatever consciousness whatever
consciousness is it comes in masculine
and feminine embodiments the masculine
and the feminine embodiment are equally
representations of God which i think is
quite remarkable because you know
there's a whole line of feminist
criticism of the Western tradition that
makes the presumption that the whole
structure is patriarchal and I don't
think that's true if it was patriarchal
it would have been man that was created
in the image of God and it is explicitly
not that
what feminine and masculine as well as
being markers for gender behavior are
also symbolic categories and the
feminine symbolic category is the the
Genetrix of things the matrix because
the female is associated with the active
with with the most fundamental aspects
of the act of reproduction so it's out
of the feminine that new forms spring
for example new forms come out of what
you don't understand that's the matrix
of being and new biological forms come
come out of a feminine substrate that's
female creatures and so the masculine
aspect is more seminal in the symbolic
sense of that the seminal idea is the
instigator so to speak and it's also it
also stands in mythology for a kind of
logical clarity and cutting whereas the
feminine stands for more like something
that's whole and undifferentiated
there's some suggestion in the story of
Adam and Eve that the woman is the
primary food sharer
and I think that's associated in some
way with her ability to make out himself
conscious which is exactly what she does
she offers him something that makes him
self conscious and she becomes self
consciousness conscious also as a
consequence in women make men self
conscious you can't think of a truth
that's truer than that and the reason
they do it is because they're very
selective and most men they reject so
God comes up and he's looking for Adam
because he's used to wandering around
with him and Adams hiding behind a bush
which says something about Adams level
of intelligence
first because you know God can see
through bushes but it also says
something about his level of
self-consciousness because what it means
is that when Adam becomes self-conscious
he no longer believes that the fact that
he was made in the image of God is
sufficient to give him stature and so
God says well who told you were naked
and this is where this is really Adams
fall I think he says it was the woman he
blames her which is really pathological
the woman you gave me it was her fault
yeah she made you self-conscious well
hooray
you know you woke up there's something
to be said for that now women torture
men into being awake and I don't suppose
that's always received with gratitude
John Milton he wrote Paradise Lost for
two reasons one was to justify the ways
of God to man and the second rationale
for his writing was to codify
mythologies stories that were in some
ways peripheral to canonical
Christianity into a single coherent
narrative here's a question he tried to
answer which was well if God was
all-knowing why would he set Adam and
Eve up to fall and Milton has a very
sophisticated answer to that and it is
that people truly have free will and
even if God knew that they were going to
fall there was nothing he could do to
stop that
except deny them free will and free will
is so valuable that that denial was not
going to happen
Dostoyevsky points out that freedom
happens to be very important to people
and even arbitrary freedom like people
want the freedom to go to hell in a
handbasket even they don't want
constraints they're willing to put up
with a lot to have their freedom and
God's judgment is something like freedom
is better than safety the snake in the
Garden of Eden is a really interesting
character human beings and their closest
biological relative chimpanzees are
innately afraid of and attracted to
reptiles they automatically trigger off
responses in a part of the brain called
the amygdala that's associated with
anxiety and I think the evolutionary
reason for this is that mammals and
reptiles have been at war in a sense
over ecological turf for something
between 60 million and 200 million years
reptilian features which are
cold-blooded piercing eyed toothed
lurking nocturnal out there out and
unknown out where chaos is the snake is
representative of the unknown in a sense
and and it's an ambivalent feature and
you see that you see that even in it's
used in mythology because for example
the dragon in in Western culture is a
negative feature but in Chinese culture
it's positive feature and so the unknown
is like that it's positive and negative
the snake in the Garden of Eden is
representative of all those things that
lurk when you think you know what you're
doing and when you think you know what
you're doing you've carved out this
little Eden this little paradise in
which you're operating but there's
always something that's lurking and
that's all the things you're not paying
attention to well that's the snake and
when that snake pops up people are we're
wired if a little snake pops out we
might want to run away from it but like
we're curious about that we're going to
go over there and investigate it right
away
now when chimps come across a Python in
the forest they have a specific cry it's
called a snake wrap and the chimps who
don't like snakes they don't run from it
they back off and then they watch the
thing they cannot tear their eyes away
from it and some of them will stand
there and look at it for 10 minutes
other individuals will stand there for
hours watching the snake the unknown is
fascinating we can't look away from it
we have to encounter it even if it's
terrifying it's partly why you know
teenagers like horror movies they're
driven to look at the snake they're
driven to interact with the snake in
Genesis of course interacting with the
snake means the end of paradise
just like it does in life there are
ideas that the serpent in the Garden of
Eden was Satan and trying to destroy
God's handiwork people often look back
in their lives and they say well you
know I got knocked out of my little
paradise by you know this particularly
back on it really made me grow up it
really made me
or whatever it is that's the serpent in
the Garden of Eden certainly plays that
role it's a catalyst much of what's
unknown is redemptive much of what's
unknown gives life savor it it provides
the kind of excitement that justifies
suffering the injunction behind
religious thought fundamentally is that
you should live your life in such a way
that the suffering it has to contain
because you're confined and vulnerable
is justified a profane world exists
because paradise always falls apart now
and that's a catastrophe that's the
human catastrophe and maybe that's
original sin and profane life is
characterized by suffering intense
suffering and that's a terrible thing
I mean it's so terrible that the first
two people to really inhabit the profane
world who can enable Cain is so
disturbed by the nature of the world
that he turns into a revengeful
homicidal resentful fascist
authoritarian and the father of war well
that's how bad that's how bad profane
existence can be but if you keep going
in the same direction you can get so
conscious that the profane conditions of
being are no longer tragic they're
acceptable but you have to live well
enough so that the suffering is worth it
if you took advantage of every
opportunity you had if you crawl through
every window that was open to you if you
lived as perfectly as you could your
life would be justifiable on its own
terms
despite its suffering and despite the
tragedy in the world
that's why Kierkegaard said that people
are redeemed one by one and not in
groups you know it's an individual
project I would say human beings are
built to take tragedy but they're not
built to take evil the most unsettling
thing isn't that a close relative dies
of cancer unsettling as that is the most
unsettling thing is to be treated
casually in a brutal manner for no other
reason than the brutality itself that's
what undermines your sense your belief
in human existence and in the value of
human existence that's what demoralizes
and kills many social scientists
radicular I would say feel that the idea
of evil is an anachronistic the reason
that evil is obliterated out of
consciousness is because we don't have a
theory to account for it Lanta we don't
have a framework within which it fits
our religious situation certainly
provides that kind of framework I also
think that we dismiss evil because it's
such a terrifying phenomena and whenever
it crops up its head everybody runs
around saying well who could have
predicted this who could have predicted
this but in all you have to do is look
and you can predict it and the people
who perpetrate it often say exactly what
they're doing and why
so the Columbine kids for example they
said something very much like well we've
taken a close look at existence and it
isn't worthy it's not worthy because
people are limited and vulnerable and
there's way too much suffering and
suffering vulnerable things are kind of
despicable and it would be better if
they were just all wiped out plus I'm
the guy to do it
and that's exactly fundamentally that's
exactly what they claimed you might say
well why would someone come to that
conclusion it's like that's not a good
answer everyone comes to that conclusion
from from time to time when they're
disappointed or frustrated or when you
know their dreams have fallen apart or
when someone near them suffers or they
doubt the utility not only of their own
existence but of existence itself if
it's taken far enough taken far enough
that attitude engenders atrocity it's
evil and I think you can define it no
problem because people say well you
can't define evil that's no that's wrong
evil is the production of suffering for
its own sake that's simple and if you
think people don't do that regularly
well you know you're just you just
haven't been looking